I wonder if you've worked out yet what
today's idea will be think back last
week we're looking at a m4 and it was
just it's just a week it's just four
little pieces to it the topic was called
modeling linear relationships do you
ever that all these kinds of pairs of
quantities and they go up together or
they go down together
that was what a.m. fort was about and v
is not about modeling linear
relationships it's about modeling
nonlinear relationships 50 things that
aren't straight lines okay so the first
kind of nonlinear relationship we're
going to have a look at is shared in
combinatorial fountains and also
satellite dishes and also objects that
move under the force of gravity I don't
know if you just have a look at this I
don't know if you can see by the context
what this is it's quite ingenious
actually whenever we as it you know you
know NASA or European Space Agency or
whoever whenever we want to go somewhere
really far away you would think that a
straight line is the most direct way or
the quickest way to get there but it's
not because to go in a straight line you
God provide all of the energy and all
the thrust and all the speed by itself
with a big rocket right so really really
smart people worked out actually there's
all these other bodies around the solar
system that we can the word they use a
slingshot we can use their gravity this
slingshot around and you trace this
particular shape when you do that oh
these guys are looking for me hold on
I know what you're here about can you
come back in about ten minutes is that
okay thanks that's right
does anyone who's anyone guessed what
the shape is that I'm interested in well
the shape that I'm interested in is the
parabola now probably the most obvious
one was this one here right and in fact
just like water traces that in fact if
you take any object
if you take I'll just use one of these
if you take any object a kill I hope
you're awake and you throw it through
the air under the force of gravity then
the path that it traces out every single
time you can throw back now if I I'm
gonna bash myself the hell's a bathroom
the part that traces out every single
time is a parabola
okay so we're really interested in these
things well you can throw really hard
you'll just get a different part of the
parabola you can't avoid it which is
kind of interesting if you throw any
object under the force of gravity it
will trace out the shape of a parabola
now if I if you do a bad throw at me
like Akhil just did right then the shape
will just be a different part of the
problem so we're interested in how to
describe these things in an illogical
way and not just saying oh it's a cool
shape but what are the one of the
numbers and symbols and equations we can
manipulate to get us this shape okay
so in your book what we're going to
start off doing will look like this now
I'm going to do the the slow and
laborious bit with you because you have
to know how to do this little boris bit
but we will very quickly give way to
using technology to do this because
that's what we do in the real world okay
so this is um this is the first question
out of I think it's chapter 1212 a must
be so you can find that confirm that for
me if you like
so the idea of a parabola we met these
equations like these guys here with
these X Squared's and that kind of thing
these have a special name these kinds of
equations here or expressions it starts
with a Q does anyone remember they're
called yeah I heard it quadratic very
good so it's been a little while since
we looked at these because we focused so
much on straight lines and what have you
so when you have a quadratic equation
then the shape that you get is a
parabola
okay now the tell-tale sign of a
quadratic is
this guy up here oh I loved it there we
go the fact that there's something and
it's squared okay in fact that's why
they call them quadratics because
squared like as in if you've got a town
square or you know you've got a square
in your school you often call that a
quadrangle right so quadratic takes its
name from the fact that it's squared
anytime you see this kind of equation
this shape it will trace out is a
parabola okay just like all those
examples I showed you before now like I
said this first bit starts off and it's
a bit slow laborious but I promise we
won't do it for very long we just need
to do it enough to get a general idea
okay so this table of values idea we've
seen this so many times the reason why
it's so useful is because no matter what
kind of equation you've got you can use
this same tool every single time so
you've probably got a calculator there
but I want you to do this first bit this
first example with me by hand okay so
we're going to complete this table of
values for all these particular values
of X at the top we're going to get some
values for y okay so when this is what I
would literally write underneath this
okay when x equals zero I'm going to
substitute that into our quadratic
equation up here just like you
substitute it into a linear equation and
I'm just going to evaluate it so it's
going to look like this y equals now
because zero is such a simple number you
might be able to work out what this is
really quickly but I'm going to do all
of the steps I'm going to say two times
zero squared
do you see that's 2x squared but I'm
substituting the X right
minus 4 times 0 plus 3 that's a really
messy 0 that look like a 6 sorry there
you go so you can see I've substituted
all my X's 4 zeros and this is really
easy to work out because all the zeros
just kind of vanish away what do you get
left with this one safe 5 it's um it's 3
because you've got 2 lots of 0 then
you've got for lots of 0 all of which is
just 0 yeah
so therefore I can say there's a value
over there when x equals 0 y equals 3
I'll do this one more time just because
it's worth getting it into your head and
you do need to do this by hand in
particular contexts excuse me let's just
do one more value so where the x equals
what I'm gonna try that out instead just
a different substitution so again I'm
gonna do it in long form like so it's a
teeny bit more complicated so 2 times 1
squared is it's late in the afternoon
isn't it
it's - last I checked four times one of
course is yep you're restoring my faith
in humanity people plus plus 3 yeah ok
the part that didn't require any
thinking ok would be so to take away 4
plus 3 is got well hold on to take away
4 is negative 2 that's ok yeah ok we're
doing well all right now thank goodness
therefore you know you really wouldn't
have to do this very many times you have
a calculator that you can of course
punch this into but you can go one step
better than that and this is going to
make things so much easier for all the
subs and questions you've got if you
haven't already can you open up your
laptop